la célèbre maison parisienne torente a
ouvert le bal des défilés hautees
couture pour le printemps et l'été
prochain cette saison des collection
sera marqué vous le savez par les adieux
mardi d'Iv SaintLaurent y SaintLaurent
qui a qualifié la haute couture de
moribonde mais ce matin sur les podium
elle a montré plutôt une belle vitalité
Sabine Gorny Olivier
tiette amour chiffon celui des riches et
belles matières amour passion celui du
travail bien fait cous des premières qui
dans le secret des ateliers depuis des
moisaffire des nuit entières à piquer
coud Brod des rêves de Rob imaginaire le
défilé va commencer elles ont encore
tellement à
faire qu'est-ce qui
manquees les perore le dos de lai va la
couture petit miracle incroyable
spectacle d'e are époque allons donc les
princesses du MoyenOrient aent à tenir
le choc
et mon carnet de B est plein à savoir
que je suis folle de joie en coulisse
perplexité des manequin à 16 ans adepte
du jein basket difficile de s'imaginer
en femme d'ambassadeur ou diplomate en
vraie princesse ou en douchesse vé bluff
la presse et les clientes tout est
question
d'attitude l'attitude couture très
glamour très glamour très
féminine couture faut être super classe
marcher de façon chaloupée bref faut
faire l'actrice sur le podium et dans le
beau monde vous croiserez de l'autruche
matière fétiche du couturier travailleer
l'été prochain en short en pantalon en
bustier ce sera pour la maison
assurément le must de l'été de la part
des clientes admiratrices salutation
distingué j'ai envie d'être là comme
j'ai envie d'aller dansune exposition de
peinture ou écouter de la musique comme
un moment suspendu de l'art du
merveilleux celui d'être projeté dans un
monde défendu rêve de petite fille
émerveillée avec la mariée qui clot le
compte de fée il sera tempant plus tard
de se
réveiller